[Music]
[Music]
the met dollar is the face thief
fashions Oscar luckily I don't care
actually as long as the English players
coming through the Dutchess of Sussex
has gone into labor Prince Harry is by
her side
who's Harry has announced that his wife
the Duchess of Sussex has given birth to
a baby boy Prince Harry could not have
looked any happier a beaming new dad he
personally wanted to tell the world
about his new son I'm very excited to
announce that myself have a baby boy
early this morning a very healthy boy
mother and baby are doing incredibly
well it's been the most amazing
experience I can ever possibly imagine
how any woman does what they do is
beyond comprehension but we're both
absolutely thrilled and so grateful to
all the love and support from everything
out there it's been it's been amazing so
I just wanted to share this with
everybody excitement in Windsor is
mounting as well fans wait to see the
new arrival for the very first time
baby boy as you can see the champagne
has already been open open flying oh no
I think we couldn't be in the target
line for getting a cork in the eye but
let's try and have a quick word before
impales
no only today Barbie to work and try to
work and I just aim it away from us at
the moment we continue to have a chat
and the news it was a boy lovely news
beautiful news wonderful news
yes I thought it was could be a boy I
mean I know that it perhaps we didn't
you know have people queuing outside the
hospital days but it was still it's
still entities back in London the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge were clearly
excited to be an aunt or their aunt the
Queen should be up in the castle now
contemplating the really good news
they're very pleased and glad to welcome
my brother to the sleep deprivation
society that is parenting so yeah I'll
be
I was plenty good boy spin advice but
now I wish him all the best and I hope
it's the next few days they can settle
down and enjoy having a newborn and
their family enjoys reality and doing so
I just haven't got that back you know
such a great tiny bit happy
[Applause]
[Music]
you beat me by one we are being
introduced to the baby for the very
first time as you can imagine there is a
lot of flash photography here we go
Archie Harrison and mountbatten-windsor
was introduced to the world today by his
proud parents Prince Harry and the
Duchess of Sussex Magic it's pretty
amazing
[Music]
and I have the two best guys in the
world
it's a little bit about um your son
what's what's he like his easy sleeping
well good baby
yes he has the sweetest temperament he's
really
it says the baby's changed so slowly
starts to grow the US Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo has made a flying visit to
London during which he met the Prime
Minister the Foreign Secretary and took
part in a roundtable about religious
freedom with the Archbishop of
Canterbury I spoke to mr. Pompeo during
his visit and asked him about Iran Iraq
and the royal baby
Archy I began asking about me his
opinion was so-called special
relationship between the UK and the USA
it has been a remarkable last couple
hundred years where we have achieved
great outcomes in two world wars in the
battles of today we work alongside each
other in Afghanistan and in Syria these
are these are important undertakings we
have deep commercial ties and I know of
no other nation that has this unique
special relationship that is lasting and
as special as the one that our two
countries have and a special dimension
now we've got Americans in the royal
family yes a wonderful addition to the
special relationship do you think don't
probably bringing an American passport
for the new baby when he comes over next
time you know I guess I do issue
passports but I'll leave that I'll leave
that to others now that I suppose the
serious the top issue for you on this
particular visit has been Iran you went
at short notice to Iraq this week what
what is the immediate threat that you
see from Iran so my trip to Baghdad was
to talk with the Iraqi leadership based
on some very specifics threats we
about Iranian activity that was taking
place that put at substantial risk our
facilities our men and women who were
serving in Iraq and I wanted to make
very clear to them that they needed to
be kept secure and the Iraqi leadership
was great have done that they're they've
they've certainly made that commitment
but we also wanted to talk to them about
the fact we know there Iraq is a
neighbor of Iran but we want to do all
the things we can to make sure that Iraq
has the opportunity be independent and
sovereign and free from interference
from any nation I mean the United
Kingdom on the question of relations
with Iran and also more significantly
economically in in terms of relations
with China is in a different position
from the United States it's not it's not
a competitor it's a trading nation that
wants to trade with both sides do you
understand that or do you think there
there was a choice facing written on for
example Huawei which he talks about when
it comes to why away and ZTE the United
States has been crystal clear we don't
believe you can have those technology in
your systems and still have a trusted
network we're happy to continue to look
at technology and see ways we might
achieve that but the United States on
for its part will only participate in
trusted networks we will only share
America's information with those
networks that we are confident are
intended the control of China or China's
government and so there's real risk if
countries choose that path that we won't
be able to participate in those networks
potentially this could threaten
Britain's security relationship with the
United States we'll find a way
I'm very confident there were two
important partners but we certainly will
never put America's national security
secrets in a network that we don't have
confidence in
the inquest has opened into the deaths
of eight people killed in the London
Bridge terror attack the coroner began
by describing the events took place on
the 3rd of June 2017 calling it a night
of high and terrible drama victims
families with MS to give 10 portraits of
their lost loved ones I spoke to the
parents of 21 year old sorrows alamak so
she smiled with her eyes she was happy
she always saw the good in everyone
she was a young a better version of
myself she was exactly the same height
and weight and we clashed a lot because
we're so alike and she planned his trip
of a lifetime with their eldest brother
who did the same trip two years prior
and she was so excited to go to London
on this amazing journey and she was
having the time of her life
doing everything 21 year olds should do
do everything before you have children
before you get into your career and she
was the happiest you'd ever been
it seems so cruel mark that when you
look at the events of that night that
they just seemed like fate was just not
working in in Tsar's way every every
decision led to this being in there just
in the wrong place at the wrong time
it definitely did I'm sorry would
normally work that Saturday night and
she was given the night off by her own
family then she was going to go to Soho
that evening and they're going to go to
a rooftop bar and that changed and then
they were heading off to a different
restaurant
Sarah's main aim and reading back
through her phone messages that she
wanted to get dressed up and go out so
that's what and it was it was just every
sliding door that could slide sleep for
sorrow to I guess put her in that
position
he's the former chancellor of the
exchequer he's switch number 11 Downing
Street for Fleet Street George Osborne
wants tip to succeed David Cameron as
Prime Minister is now editor of The
Evening Standard a position from which
he's been a prominent critic of brexit
an of Theresa May she asked at him from
government in the months after the UK
voted to leave the EU I sat down with
him in Manchester where he told me it's
time for her to go eventually the party
has to confront the truth which is it
needs a new leader it needs a new agenda
it needs to win over supporters who have
disappeared from it and it needs to make
an appeal to urban metropolitan Britain
that has currently turned their back on
conservatism and if that's the case if
that continues to be the trend and there
won't be a Conservative government why
do you think she's hanging on in there
do you think it's because she's trying
to protect her own legacy or is she
trying to govern in the national
interest I mean what do you think it is
well I think Teresa made obviously
really wants to deliver her brexit deal
but she has not gotten the numbers to do
that and all she's got left is hoping
that Jeremy Corbyn a person who she
every day says is unfit for national
office to come to a rescue to keep her
in national office and that is not in my
mind a successful plan for a prime
minister I heard that you had said to
someone why would a Corbin who wants to
be in government save a drowning Prime
Minister the incentives on an opposition
are to replace the government because
you think generally you'd do a better
job and so I think any opposition leader
would be very hard-pressed to rescue a
dying Prime Minister I think there's a
point where you have to ask yourself as
a political party how many more
elections are we going to lose so we
lost the majority in 2017 we got
hammered in the local elections earlier
this month and now we've got these
European elections where it's quite
possible that the conservative body for
the first time in its long and
distinguished history is going to come
for
in a national poll and essentially
there's a responsibility on the current
members of parliament and indeed the you
know supporters in the country to do
something about that
and it's within their hands you know
there's you can't just say there's all
beyond my control if you remember the
cabinet you have a responsibility and I
as it happens I was giving them any
advice I would suggest to them
individually if they want to lead
fortune favors of the brave in these
leadership contests the second series of
Sky Atlantic drama Riviera is set for
release later this month a story of
power money and murder on the Cote
d'Azur
Hollywood actress Julia Stiles returns
in a leading role as she struggles to
regain control at the top of the class
family and we learn more about her
troubled history we all have a secret
stone i sat down with her this week to
find out more she was sort of this
guileless innocent optimistic girl who
now had all this tragedy heaped on her
and because of her actions at the end of
season one she has to just put one foot
in front of the other and and she's
determined to prove to herself that
she's not a sociopath but also maintain
her power and position and so she is
quite corrupted by the world that she
lives in
I couldn't have anticipated exactly how
much this was going to be about the
women of the Riviera but I I'm so proud
to be part of a show that mean something
that something a show like this could so
easily be about the billionaire men and
the the male business men and certainly
we have our girls in bikinis and we have
all the the glitz and the glamour but
and women who are rivals with each other
but but really the the powerhouses in
the and the the movers and shakers are
the female characters right now as an
actress I'm more excited about the
opportunities coming my way and also for
my peers I do think that that there are
some amazing
female-driven trolls on TV then I
suppose a defining role and film for a
generation was out of cat in 10 Things I
Hate About You
she didn't have to change the way she
was to attract the guy mm-hm and it's
still relevant today well and her goal
wasn't to attract the guy which I
thought was an interesting and new I
wanted that part so badly because it was
the first time that I had read a
character of a teenage girl with who's
so feisty and contrarian I mean you look
at what's going on in u.s. politics and
you look at the Malheur investigation
and talk of Russian collusion and
Twitter rouse that are going on I mean
it could be a Hollywood screenplay at
the moment could meant um I look forward
to the day when it becomes a movie and
we can look back on this fleeting time
in US history no runner in history has
ever broken the two-hour barrier for a
marathon
realistically Elliot Kip chaga of Kenya
is the only person who could ever dare
to dream of doing so at Italy Road in
Oxford the track for Sir Roger Bannister
famously ran the first ever sub
four-minute mile in May 1954 for time
London Marathon winner and world record
holder kif Choga
has announced a fresh bid to make
history by running 26.2 miles in less
than a hundred twenty minutes tell me
how much of running is mental you've
always said that the strongest thing is
a peaceful mind
you can't run when you are not fit but
above all what tires actually a man or a
man pin is the conscience so mental [ __ ]
is actually up in the upper hand in in
running course is the moment you are fit
enough and you are poor mentally you can
you can do anything what drives you to
break this barrier we wrote a faster
broker a foreman career
as 6th May 1954 and I tried to crack a
two hour barrier on 16 May 2017 so it's
a quick relationship and what travels me
to do to these Hercules to live the
legacy in sport it's too much to tell
the community or the family of a human
being that you can cope you know you are
your capability that's why I always say
no your money's limited what will this
mean for your legacy we know what you've
achieved in life and what you will
always be remembered for but if you can
break the two hour barrier your
great-grandchildren the whole world will
remember Elliott keep jogging if you do
this you and all to remember all that
Martin triple in a human community Ike a
little to know that a sport is whereby
you can get pretty little sport is the
professional by other professionals are
running there to get the freedom and we
wish you the best of luck and we will be
there when you do thank you coming up
extravagant outfit took center stage at
one of the world of fashions biggest
events the Met Gala in New York the
theme for attendees was camp notes on
fashion and who do you think that is oh
yeah Lady Gaga changed four times on the
red carpet arriving in that hot pink
gown before revealing a black evening
dress which is very lovely
followed by a second pink number before
ending her run on the red carpet in
sparkling lingerie at meanwhile Katy
Perry chose to wear a chandelier Janelle
monáe completed her dress with a
blinking eye and Jared Leto carried his
own
what is the net cover well so the Met
Gala is effectively fashions Oscars once
a year they throw together everything
they can for to coincide with an event
at the Metropolitan Music Museum of Art
so for example this year there is going
to be an exhibition devoted to camp
based on a very serious high art essay
by Susan Sontag so what they do is Anna
Wintour editor of Vogue she brings
together she's the co-chair but she very
cleverly brings in sort of people of the
moment to be her co-chairs and so the
idea is that they fate there's a lot of
attention and thus the pictures that we
saw last night okay who particularly
caught your attention well I mean I'm
never gonna go far beyond Celine Dion
for a bit of camp and she did not
disappoint shit-shit-shit she was
wearing a sort of people have compared
it with a spaghetti drainer
if you're being roll I only took several
thousand hours to make all of these all
these things do I mean they're probably
the effort involved is my bobbing the
tickets per person alone are $30,000 and
then you add in the dresses and the
jewels but I mean if anybody can carry
off a spaghetti Greiner it is Celine
deal the man who masterminded England's
journey to a World Cup semi-final last
summer Gareth Southgate is taking part
in a scheme to teach young people about
leadership I caught up with the England
manager at an event hosted by the
Prince's Trust where he told me why the
initiative matters to him and also gave
the sports on next month's Champions
League final between Liverpool and
Topman I think when you're young you're
working all of those things out in your
life you don't know maybe necessarily
exactly what you want to do and you
assume that everybody that's older and
appears successful on the outside that
life's been a breeze for them and
generally speaking all the successful
people I've ever met that hasn't been
the case you in England had incredible
success do you kind of brace yourself
for when the results are not quite so
good well I've had a fair amount of
failure as well with England so I'm
pretty well adapted to what that might
be
and you you know that for every success
there will be difficult times but as a
leader you've got to take the rest of
the group through those difficult times
and
keep them on track keep them focused on
the vision ahead and lead them through
those difficult spells they're the
biggest challenges for leaders it's been
the most extraordinary 48 hours can you
quite believe what you witnessed with
these two wins by Liverpool and
Tottenham I was at Anfield on Tuesday so
left there thinking I'd seen one of the
most think I've been in football 30
years one of the most incredible nights
I can remember for it then to be backed
up by Tottenham on Wednesday was
phenomenal I mean huge credit to both
managers in different circumstances
they've achieved incredible seasons and
from an England perspective brilliant
for all of our players that they're
having these experiences in big matches
where they're having to play under
pressure and they've come out
successfully is it good for England
though because you've got this issue now
haven't you well it's mate it's making
things more complicated that's for sure
because reality is we all get seven or
eight of those players three days before
our semi finals so you have great ideas
as a manager of planning things and
working with the team and in truth we'll
have half of our squad that won't be
with us until three days before so who's
gonna win the Champions League it's been
a remarkable year in that competition
and anything is possible and luckily I
don't care actually as long as the
English players come through and play
well and stay fit then I'm happy
you